I just saw a video where the girls like
imagine not liking me cause I'm living the life with him that you wanted
and she's kinda being like smug about it
and like at first of course I wanna be like Ew
but you know what
if you could be bothered like that
that's a you issue
if seeing somebody with that man gets you like
all worked up and bothered
that is dead ass a you issue
she's happy as fuck
look at her eating her fucking fast food in her car
talking about her man
you're the one all hot and bothered
do you know what I mean
d center men from your life
a man is most definitely not the most important thing in your life
a man is most definitely not gonna always add to your life
they can be fun
I'm not saying don't have them around
but I'm just saying like
figure your shit out so that a man
is it so fucking important that some chick
eating her fucking hash Browns in her car is gonna get you pissed off
get it you know what I mean
if you could get that bothered
that says something about you
it doesn't mean the man is so fucking great
you need to be crying and chasing him
it means like
where are you in your own heart that you're getting this worked up over like
another person
you know what I mean